[Music]
we shoot this show in Los Angeles uh-huh
fantastic city yes she is my lady yeah
yeah la it's my lady oh that's weird
well this was a big story here there was
a bear on the loose in a suburban Los
Angeles neighborhood yesterday the local
news was all over this story as you can
imagine crazy footage take a look at
this the bear it's a giant looks like a
brown bear to me because he's brown yeah
but he's climbing over fences he's going
into people's yards he was wandering all
over the place of driveways yeah now
animal control it did arrive they
tranquilized the bear he's fine released
him back into the wild okay but we have
been asked to remind everyone who's
watching summer is coming okay and with
summer coming the Bears will be out and
around
if you encounter a bear whatever you do
do not disturb it okay just let the bear
do what it does until Animal Control
arrives
yeah that's it's really the only
sensible we've a bear in the studio
somehow don't move guys okay okay this
way
okay just take
just let him okay let him do what he's
gonna do just let's back up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]